wenn das bei euch klappt dann verkaufe
ich meine unterhosen bei ebay wenn paar
sekunden später bot
meine damen und herren einen ganz ganz
ganz ganz großen applaus mitte für
unseren heutigen tag danke danke danke
schön und damit herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einer neuen folge von luca
reagiert dem geschützten das format auf
ganz youtube erst mal leute wie fällt
ihr überhaupt keine deko hier
ich habe ein umgedrehtes ikea bild unten
mülleimer kann man kann man schon mal
klatschen allerdings haben wir uns ja
heute nicht versammelt um über meine
deko zu sprechen sondern ihr habt mir
wieder unfassbar tolle videos bei
twitter zugewendet und auf die reagiere
ich heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf
danke für das liebesgeständnis zeigt
dass mit julia irgendwann nicht mehr
richtig funktionieren sollte werde ich
mit diesem scharfen dann zusammenkommen
ich meine wir sehen es ja auch
eigentlich relativ ähnlich okay beim
ihrer schule war es so wir hatten in den
pausen zeit unser brot zu essen haben
uns auf den unterricht vorbereitet und
diese leute hier die neben idee und
machen daraus einen flammenwerfer bei
diesem video sehen wir paar kleine
kinder hat sie sich als zombies
verkleidet haben also werten und hätte
ja den kinofilm da sind so riesige
roboter maschine die können sich dann zu
autos verwandeln indem die sich dann
irgendwie doch so einfahren die sache
ist ich hatte selber früher auch so
schon jetzt voraus kost wie man karneval
und dachte hat okay ich hab das anders
ist mega cool dann kann ich nichts in
der karre machen wenn ich mich hinlegen
was hat nie geklappt diese kostüme sind
einfach voll fürn arsch wenn das klappt
dann verkaufe ich meine unterhose bei
ebay
[Musik]
wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen
ich gehe mal eben auf ebay
also hier steht artikel einstellen über
160 millionen käufer wollen was sie
haben angebot erstellen genau
beschreiben sie ihren artikel unterhose
von luca ich habe jetzt einfach mal
calvin klein unterhose eingegeben
dann kommen die hier und jetzt muss ich
den ganzen sachen ausfüllen also ich hab
da mal in ebay rein und dann sage ich
gleich mal das angebot da da bin ich mit
meiner boxershorts ukas unterhose weiß
noch wie neu
angaben zum verkäufer oder ist mein name
mensch reza luca 69 ich glaube ich habe
ein bisschen was falsch ausgewählt hier
steht das ist neu mit etikett neuer
unbenutzt auch nicht getragen
lange unterhosen
kommt drauf an wie man langen definiert
hier hab ich dann auch noch meine
unterhose beschrieben
das ist meine unterhose in weiß größe l
super teil
also wer die nicht kaufen will sollte es
geht bei 1 euro los linke es in der
beschreibung der hat echt was verpasst
und ich bin jetzt nackt untenrum aber
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten video
korrekt alter danke dass ein sushi
abgeschossen und das gefilmt hat ich
habe übrigens auch einen nerv kann
[Musik]
da sieht man dass sich 1980 im krieg
waren
[Applaus]
was tun
was mache ich mit meinem leben sk was
ist los ihren frau eine kurze info
bezüglich meine shops und zwei gibt es
gerade noch 250 signiertes dk die bei
jeder bestellung dabei liegen bei jedem
produkt wo eine regenbogenflagge oben
dran ist denn hier also einerseits ein
reduziertes produkt haben wollt und
einen signierten sticker also eine
autogrammkarte von mir dann wirklich
jetzt mal schnell in den shop gehen und
bestellen weil sie die url nicht kennt
die es einfach nur was das schöne wenn
du die realtech nett wenn man irgendwie
was ließ und man weiß nie was es
bedeutet und googelt man das einfach
aber was ist bei seiner melodie das ist
irgend ein medley von ihnen das serie
oder irgendwas schreibt damit in die
kommentare
julia scheiße die band gerade was ist da
ist okay das ist von ihnen der serie 3 2
bitte in die kommentare und bitte
beleidigt mich nicht als druck
[Musik]
und es geht noch weiter ich hasse dieses
format
ich mache zwar kein youtube aber manni
ist bei mir trotzdem am start und er
schiebt sie sich das alles in den
baureihen du bist wirklich ein
kompletter vollidiot es ist geradezu
ultra kalt dass ich noch jacke anziehen
glückwunsch aber darunter ist natürlich
klar ihren mann wie gesagt wer den
unterschriebenen sticker haben wollt
dann klickt einfach in der beschreibung
auf den link luca mine schaffen und de
oder wartet auf den ersten 12
da kommen neue produkte in den shop die
wir schon beim planen sind mega ich sag
mal das wird wieder back to basics
konkreter alter macht immer nur werbung
[Applaus]
das ist das könnte das ist wirklich das
kann den grammy und oscar gewinnen die
spiele besser fußball ist unsere
deutsche nationalmannschaft das meine
damen und herren waren die tsl die band
an beuys die machen pop und sind unserer
unserer bekannt in der szene wollt ihr
das nicht mal wieder darauf reagiere
viele leute sagen dass nämlich immer und
meinen auch halo kaufte jedoch nicht die
rechte hast ist doch scheißegal was
einfach hoch auch wenn es nicht am
online ist jeder einfach mal wieder
drauf
vollidiot wenn ihr das wollt dann
schreibt gern mal in die kommentare bts
[Musik]
warum zum fixing jemand eine ratte film
ist sie aber eigentlich echt relativ
süße hh du bist die springt da ich
selber auf die kamera zu oder so
ist nicht auf die kamera zu gesprungen
aber ist runtergefallen ich glaube es
gibt möglichkeiten menschen der spinnen
so krass hast wie ich wirklich bin
ziemlich sauer und habe freude dass
gleich ein paar milliliter video seht
ihr noch nicht abonnent von meinem
kleinen klickt unter dem video abonniert
ist doch vorlag
warum liege ich in deinem mülheimer
andere frage warum nicht den handy in
einen mülleimer
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll kein
scheiß
das ist immer das ding auf irgendwelchen
zuschauer treffen ist hier immer wenn
ich leute treffe sagen sie mir halt voll
häufig haye macht eine videoaufnahme für
meinen freund ben oder nicht mehr
verwenden
tauben ich meine was soll man da sagen
jemand filmt dich du kennst diese person
vielleicht gar nicht oder gerade mal
seit 10 sekunden und dann einfach nur so
hey hier ist luca mich auf dustin
schönen tag falls du irgendwann ihr
letztes geburtstag hat jetzt alles gute
nachträglich passt mal gut in der schule
auf ich bin luca lg dein freund luca ich
finde das immer ganz komisch solche
situationen da mal heißt ich hierzu luca
oder was wird mir erst eine spinne
geschickt dann hatte und jetzt auch noch
so ein ding mit augen
[Musik]
also wirklich erst mal einer von euch
dass die luca wieder schaffung der die
tafel geschrieben habe die sache ist nur
im hintergrund hat irgendjemand klavier
gespielt und das sind so diese typischen
leute so hey wir haben vergleiche ist
musikunterricht ist mir schon ans
klavier und zeigt allen die cool ich
spielen kann kein scheiß ich hasse diese
leute die haben auf gymnasium immer die
mädels bekommen weil sie dann vom
unterricht wie spiel konnten und was
kann ich ich kann mich beim ich hab gar
nichts pauli schon wieder mitte was
richtig gut klavier spielen kann
wenigstens kann die mir nicht die mädels
wegschnappen das war es auch schon hier
mit diesen die ja das war es auch schon
wieder mit diesem wie wenn ihr auf
klickt passiert gar nichts
das ist nicht mein auto allerdings sind
ihr gleich mein auto werde denn das hier
ist das letzte video auf dass ich heute
reagieren wollte freunde am ihr seht
schon im hintergrund ist alles ein
bisschen durcheinander wie gesagt da
steht ein mülleimer dass ein umgedrehtes
ikea bild hier ist auch ein mülleimer
ich schreibe gerade jemand hoffen damit
ein bisschen um deswegen entschuldigt
die komplette unordnung ermessen lebt
ihr noch da habe ich euch kurz eine
kleine backpfeife gegeben
liefke media
[Musik]